سيوله نقديه تقدر بسبعه عشر مليار دولار
في هذا العام وارتفاع عائدات التصدير
النفط والغاز الى 60 مليار دولار العام
الماضي هكذا يبدو المشهد في القطاع
المصرفي الجزائري ولكن في المقابل تعاني
البلاد ضعف الاستثمارات الاجنبيه المباشره
بين ان مستوى التفاؤل ارتفع بعد اقرار
قانون النقد والقرض الذي يمنح مرونه اكبر
للبنوك في تحويل ارباح الشركات الاجنبيه
للخارج وتشجيع التعاملات الالكترونيه
ادوات لم تكن متاحه وتسبب غيابها على مدار
سنوات في عرقله اداء قطاعات اقتصاديه عده
من بينها السياحه وهو امر يعكس على ما
يبدو المساهمه المتواضعه للقطاع السياحي
في اجمالي الناتج المحلي للجزائر مع
النظام النقدي الجديد حيث كنا فرصه لان
حتى نجلبوا اكثر الاجانب يتعاملوا معنا
يمنح القانون المعدل صلاحيات لمجلس النقد
والقرض لاعتماد البنوك الاستثماريه وانشاء
الدينار الرقمي الجزائري كما يمنحه
الصلاحيات لاعتماد مقدمي خدمات الدفع
الالكتروني والوسطاء المستقلين ويرخص فتح
مكاتب الصرف جاب صلاحيات اوسع لمحافظ بنك
الجزائر بالشكل اللي يخليه يتحكم اكثر في
السوق النقديه والماليه ويعطيها اكثر
مرونه ويخرجها من الحواجز البيروقراطيه
ويامل خبراء ان تنفذ الحكومه بشكل فعلي
وشفاف عمليه طرح راس مال عدد من البنوك
العموميه امام القطاع الخاص والالتزام
بالقانون الجديد الذي يقضي بسحب مساهمه
الخزينه العموميه من البنوك الخاصه
يجب العمل اكثر والقيام
بالاليات الاساسيه على ارضيه الميدان حتى
تحرر البنوك من
الوصايه وتنظر الاوساط الاقتصاديه بعين
التفاؤل الى اعتماد مكاتب الصرف الرسميه
للنقد الاجنبي بوصفها احد ابرز الرهانات
الوارده في الاصلاحات الجديده حيث يقبل ان
تنهي سطوه السوق السوداء تماما
ويبقى التحدي الذي يواجه القطاع المصرفي
الجزائريه هو مدى قدره البنوك على تعزيز
ايراداتها بعد ان تتوسع بافتتاح فروع لها
في الخارج فالاصلاحات الجديده الملقاه على
عاتق البنك المركزي اشرافا ومراقبه غايتها
تطوير الخدمات وتعزيز الارباح
الجزيره الجزائر